all right I'm Pat hey we're hanging out  tonight  I hope you want to go to some junkyard  and do what drink beer out of a paper  bag  [Music]  I'll see you at 8:00 what you're working  with this is the good stuff  stems and see you guys have anything  stronger in this town or what I'll give  you something to I want you to sell it I  can help you yeah we've made an app what  is this where's the rest of the trucks  twelve dead in this county promoting his  last year six of my minors you're up you  trust her  first cook we have to give me something  following me look into school you go  ahead  you waiting for there's a need to tell  you I ain't going to jail for your  mistakes  decided what  are you gonna do  normally trust you I don't care if you  trust me  you should  you